to make the coins yellow first I'll use
get show to look at the changes
introduced by the color commit scrolling
down I can see that within the ship the
color was set to Navy and solid was set
to true similarly within the asteroid
the color was set to light gray and
solid was set to true that probably
means that I have to add lines like this
to the coin object next I want to
compare the first commit before coins
were introduced to the final coin commit
I can find the IDS for those by using
git log - - Graaff - - one-line so I'll
use git diff and here's the latest
commit before the coins branch and
here's the latest commit with coins so
if I scroll down a bit there were a lot
of changes but I can see that the coin
was introduced here so I'll open the
file game j/s and search for coin and
once I find the correct place then I'll
add the lines this dot color equals
yellow and this dot solid equals true
now I'll save the file and check whether
it worked and here's a yellow coin so it
looks good now I'll double check what my
changes were using git diff add them and
commit them and I'll use the commit
message make coins yellow